you know what I'm not even gonna comment
on that so as listeners to dear Hank and
John will already know I am a huge fan
of the movie Rushmore and within that
movie there is a place that during the
Vietnam War in which a character is
asked how long you've been in country
and the soldier replies I ain't even
here sergeant I'm in Cheyenne Wyoming
anyway Cheyenne Wyoming has since become
my personal shorthand for the place I
visit when I am deeply immersed in a
project like when we first started
making Blood Brothers back in 2007 I
spent several months in Cheyenne Wyoming
because I wasn't really where ever I
physically was I was always thinking
about what my next video was gonna be
about or how to grow our audience or
about how cool YouTube was but mostly I
visit Cheyenne Wyoming when I'm writing
now in a lot of ways being in Cheyenne
is super fun like one of my primary
complaints about human life is that we
spend the entire enterprise stuck inside
of one particular slowly decaying body
and living inside a made-up world has
always allowed me to feel kind of free
from that like free from the twin
prisons of my consciousness and my body
but also for much of my life Cheyenne
has been kind of an escape like all
those years when I didn't have many real
friends and I felt intensely lonely I
could always go to Cheyenne where people
would like me because you know I'd made
them up that said when I'm in Cheyenne
I'm also kind of you know like not here
which means that sometimes I'll be at
dinner with my kids and not answer when
I'm asked a question I neglect daily
responsibilities I forget to get
haircuts I've been in Cheyenne Wyoming
for quite a while now and I expect to be
here a while longer and it can be really
frustrating because I actually like my
real life and I like making videos every
Tuesday and I'm not all the way here and
I worry I should be because the other
thing about going to Cheyenne is that
you aren't necessarily going to come
home with anything like I spent about a
year in Cheyenne finishing The Fault in
Our Stars but I also spent several
months there a few years ago only to
realize that the book I'd worked so hard
on wasn't very good and wasn't gonna be
published for me at least I can't know
until after I immerse myself in the work
which is frustrating and scary but you
know what actually no but it's just
frustrating and scary at the moment Hank
in your video last week you talked about
how to be productive and I thought you
gave very helpful and astute advice but
I think creative productivity is
somewhat different because for one thing
you have to spend time in ways that
markets and our culture don't really
recognize as productive like reading or
pacing or staring out the window and
then
once you get deep enough into the work
you have to make space in your life and
ask the people around you to make space
in their lives for you to go to Cheyenne
Wyoming now that doesn't mean working
all day every day I wrote my first two
books at night after work and wrote them
quicker than I have any book since but
it does mean that a certain percentage
of your intellectual and emotional self
will be absent for a while then you make
what you can of your time in Cheyenne
and then maybe most importantly you come
home to your body to the sense8 world to
the real people you really love unless
you live in the actual Cheyenne Wyoming
in which case the whole metaphor sort of
falls apart anyway that's as close as I
can get at the moment to advice on how
to make stuff and I also want to say I'm
sorry if I haven't been around enough
lately I will come home at some point
in the meantime I miss you Hank I'll see
you on Friday
and screen hi two things first over on
my Facebook page I made a video
sponsored by Google about being internet
kind in which I talk about my early life
online way back in the 1990's there's a
link in the doobly-doo below and
secondly if you're gonna be at VidCon in
Anaheim in a couple weeks there is a
nerdfighter gathering Thursday morning
at 9:30 where Hank and I are gonna get
to announce some exciting new complexly
projects very excited for it hope to see
you there thanks bye